well thank you very much and it is
wonderful to see so many people together
on Friday afternoon who are interested
in in food those of us said the School
of Public Health are looking at food
very intensively we have been for many
years and this is basically through the
lens of how does food affect health
that's probably most the most
fundamental question we have
specifically how how different foods
affect health differently if we're going
to have policies around food or for they
may be national policies international
policies or whether we're giving dietary
guidelines about food choices it's
really fundamentally important to have
the best possible information about how
our dietary choices affect our long-term
health and well-being that's I that's an
important question it's not so always
straightforward to answer that question
ideally we would conduct large
randomized trials to address every
question we have such as what is the
optimal egg consumption what is the
optimal trans fat consumption but for
practical reasons those kinds of
randomized trials are often very
difficult logistically unfit to conduct
and often and feasible but when they can
be conducted the worst aspect of
randomized trials is it they can often
give totally misleading answers mainly
because it's very difficult to assure
that individuals maintain the diet to
which they are signed for many years
especially if you're conducting Studies
on the scales of tens of thousands of
people which you need to look at some of
these items some of these questions the
next best kind of information will
usually be large prospective studies
where people are eating the diet's they
choose but we measure and track their
diets over time and look at their diets
in relation to health outcomes if that
information in combination with
short-term intervention
studies control feeding studies at last
two or three weeks with a few dozen
people looking at biochemical or
physiological changes that combination
of these short-term control feeding
studies and long-term cohort studies in
most cases will probably be the best
available evidence that we'll be able to
have on the relationship between aspects
of diet and health outcomes so our group
has invested much of its information
much of our effort for the last almost
40 years looking at diet and health in
large cohort studies the first was a
Nurses Health Study 121,000 women who
were enrolled in 1976 and we started
collecting dietary data in 1980 using
details standardized and validated
questionnaires and we a very importantly
updated dietary intake over time to
account for people's individual changes
the choices in their diet and also the
fact that the food supply is continually
evolving over time along the way we've
collected blood samples and toenails for
biomarkers the nurses health study
included only women so we added fifty
two thousand men as the health
professionals follow-up study and to
look at diet earlier in life we added
the nurses health study to another
hundred and sixteen thousand women and I
want to point out that this is the work
of a large number of people many some of
whom I've listed at the bottom here but
there are many other people who have
contributed importantly to this work
overtime so we're tracking diet over
time and were also essentially tracking
incidents of basically all major
diseases that occur in this population
just to give a few examples that we
published many hundreds of papers
looking at a specific specific aspects
of diet and different health outcomes
this is looking at risk of coronary
heart disease is a function of different
types of dietary fat and this is based
on 14 years of follow-up 1982 1994
during that time about a thousand women
died of coronary heart disease or were
hospitalized for acute myocardial
function and we're looking here at a
different increasing energy from
different types of fat controlling for
total energy intake and as I've done
we've done in all the slides I show
we've adjusted very carefully for
smoking physical activity and other
variables that could be confounding so
what it shows is by far the worst type
of trent of that was trans fat saturated
fat compared to carbohydrate the
comparison here was minimally related to
risk of heart disease but mono and
polyunsaturated fat were related to
reduced risk of heart disease we can
also look at not just the nutrients but
also the basic foods and food groups
that people consume so this is looking
at substitution of one major protein
source for another in relation to risk
of coronary heart disease here based on
26 years of follow-up and the main
message is at the bottom there if you
want to reduce heart disease it's
replacing red meat with poultry fish
nuts or or beans or some combination of
those presumably not just about one of
those this is a similar kind of analysis
looking at type 2 diabetes I whether
it's not slow fat dairy whole grains
poultry or fish all of those are
associated with lower risk if they
replace red meat in the diet I could go
on with lots of other examples but just
to give an idea of another kind of way
of looking this looking at outcomes this
is looking at the percent of avoidable
coronary heart disease by adopting a
whole package of healthy lifestyles
including not smoking avoiding
overweight or obesity incorporating
moderate to vigorous activity and a
healthy diet and we create the created a
dietary score here based on trans fat
cereal fiber glycemic load high poly
unsaturated the saturated fat ratio and
also moderate alcohol consumption so the
bottom line was that we could prevent
potentially in ninety two percent this
is type 2 diabetes in the population of
the nurses health study if everybody
adopted this healthy
lifestyle package so the potential for
prevention of chronic disease is huge
this is a type 2 diabetes we see about
eighty percent potential reduction of
coronary heart disease and very high
percentages of some cancers as well but
very few people are adopting this the
full package even though it's actually
pretty reasonable in this particular
analysis analysis only about four
percent of our participants that adopted
that package of healthy lifestyle
variables even though it seemed pretty
moderate so there's a we have a lot more
work to do identifying all of the health
effects of different aspects of diet
we've done a lot but there is also a
huge gap between what we know and what
is possible to do in terms of disease
prevention by healthy diet thank you